es ist wirklich eine zeit in der es
nichts zu feiern gibt und in der wir
versuchen müssen jetzt die
infektionszahlen würden sie jetzt raten
schon mal einzuladen oder auch gerade
das einmal ich würde jetzt erst einmal
raten dass wir das noch einige wochen
ertragen und dass wir jetzt alles daran
setzen dass diese situation eintritt die
wir uns wünschen dass eine entspannung
gibt und dass wir vielleicht auch
maßnahmen über die weihnachtsfeiertage
machen können die etwas stärker einer
anderen bereich zurück bringen und dann
vielleicht ermöglichen dass wir
einigermaßen dass das weihnachtsfest
feiern können aber es bleibt bei dieser
erkenntnis dass gerade familien feiern
ja dadurch gekennzeichnet ist dass die
ältere generation mit der jüngeren
zusammenkommt und da sind wir wieder in
diesem dilemma dieses virus das ist ja
kein problem der regierung oder der
verordnung dieses virus hat diese
eigenschaft dass es die ältere
generation so gefährdet und alle anderen
aber die übertragung machen können vater
ist völlig verzweifelt mit aller kraft
versucht er in sein brennendes haus zu
gelangen denn in dieser flammenhölle
steckt vermutlich noch seine kleine
tochter mia sophie unfassbare drei
stunden muss vater michael mit ansehen
wie die einsatzkräfte im dachstuhl des
hauses nach der dreijährigen suchen um
19 uhr ist es dann traurige gewissheit
die kleine mia sophie hat es nicht mehr
aus dem haus geschafft und stirbt beim
dachstuhlbrand dieses schreckliche feuer
drama spielt sich am samstag im
oberfränkischen helmbrechts ab gegen
15.50 wird vater michael schiller von
der feuerwehr alarmiert sofort kehren er
seine frau sarah und sohn kim vom
einkaufen heim doch aus ihrem haus in
der hochstraße schießen schon meterhoch
die flammen
die einsatzkräfte der polizei und
feuerwehr und schnell vor ort allerdings
er konnte ein dreijähriges mädchen nicht
mehr geredet werden und konnte nur noch
tot aufgefunden werden
das nesthäkchen mia sophie hat mit ihrem
bruder john auf dem dachboden gespielt
in einem verschlossenen nachbar abteil
sollen stromleitungen offen gelegen
haben wahrscheinlich hat sich die kleine
beim brand vor angst in einer holztruhe
versteckt während bruder john mit seiner
schwester samantha noch aus dem haus
rennen konnte wir haben nichts mehr sagt
vater michael schiller später zu bild er
braucht spenden und material um schnell
eine wohnung für seine anderen drei
kinder und seine frau herrichten zu
können
die brandursache steht laut polizei noch
nicht fest
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren